can't support you can't grow a lot of yo
go to farmers markets with me on this
trip homemade food preserves ok I don't
know if anybody never take preserves
rhubarb either ever pigs grow well with
no care at all in the south they have
predictable
I made these figs my children help me
pick FIGS two weeks ago we made feet
preserves from their great-great
grandmother's big tree okay my kids know
about climbing in it they know about
picking they're all back sorting mouth
into it ended up getting too bad without
cutting the stems off all those details
make it for you when the revolution
comes my wife there's a hotshot lawyer
she said that lawyers gonna be among the
first to be lined up and shot today but
people who can grow food will be spared
so my kids so I think know that they've
been to Vermont and they know that they
can get Vermont maple syrup and
everything legally don't know what
Piggly Wiggly is
the wheel in Mississippi has a lot maple
syrup it you've got the know somebody to
get omega-3 okay
this is slow food this also slope
gardening because we jointly and we will
have something sweet in the middle by
the way I want a case of this they
swapped me out some strawberry is this
is he playing at home I think it's not
gonna hurt to eat it is
so that's what's left argument if you
want a real run I've got a list of a few
things that you can do that you're
already doing these things but you don't
think about okay you don't think about
sharing with others you don't think
about talking with children about garden
there's some fantastic children start
dollar
all over the country but all you have to
do is bend down and wiggle your finger
in the grass and talk about whatever the
child if you lucky it'll be our only
hope the child and engage them you can
change that child attitude about not
only in the world but maybe that
grown-ups okay
so that's what slow guarding is go to my
website do what he had just said Yanis
non-commercial all right don't keep
track of who goes there
click on the think house slow garden
and see if it's not things that you
already do that maybe just haven't
focused on and that's my job here today
just relax it again I want to throw out
one last thing before we go
this poetry reading they have a Bible
tree
okay the bottle tree a lot of people
don't get okay so where you take an old
tree that died and stick bottles on the
branch
okay we've been assisting cursed okay
you know when you go up the towel about
halfway up they got that window with all
the glass in it in the wintertime
particularly people up north have
colorful plants bottles in your window
you know I'm talking about don't you and
the reason you do that because in
wintertime your pineal gland that thing
that affects your attitude shrieks up
okay forget what they call seasonal
affective disorder the blues you put a
little console glass in the window and
it stimulates you love it it sparks you
up okay well bomber trees are just taken
in a half a yard by the way some people
don't like by the trees my way of
thinking is you think this okay to hang
stuff out of holes in their ears get
shut up these part we call a context
on the side with all because them all
all the time he was having fun okay any
questions
you know already isn't coming back
little balls is that good or bad
who says it's good
doesn't cater
poverty intervals and that food
this can turn into a TV show companies
maybe you shouldn't do that stuff cause
it's not natural folks
neither is plucking eyebrows looking at
stuff okay lighten up in the radio she
said my name is Annie and my colleague
Pat and I are working on Vince garden
and a couple of other gardens around
campus and we'd like to invite Lee or
another
that are not forever part of the
conference but if here after the
conference for every Wednesday we have a
meeting Wednesday we meet in the man
courtyard at noon we give out free ice
cream and we go around to all the
different Gardens we do weaning weeding
and we talk about you know the different